hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from round two of this
year's fide World Cup there are so many
games being played and so many of them
are a really high quality and it would
be it would not be a crime to show them
but uh I have to choose carefully some
of them really are more special than
others uh and I really try to bring all
the nicest ones so here we have a game
between Paraguay Grandmaster Axel
Bachmann and Indian Grandmaster nihal
sarin uh there are some of you have been
wondering there are now uh there are now
six Indian players in the uh world that
are rated over 2700 and nihal uh is very
very close to being number seven I think
uh pragnananda is already over 2700
degrees is over 2700 Hari Krishna
pentala is uh she's anandis and uh I I
think there's one more uh let me just
quickly check
I don't want to trick you guys uh
I don't want to trick you guys yeah and
with it yeah with it is also of course
over 2700 and now uh nihal has a chance
to be number seven and it's a really
really uh brutal game because this is
game two of their match and Michal won
game one with the white piece so now
axel needs the bonds back in order to
force tie breaks and those are the best
kind of games so let's see what happened
here uh Axel has the white pieces and he
opens with C4 he goes for the English
opening with Fanta E6 G3 and now Pawn to
D5 the Asian core defense of the English
opening Bishop to G2 and now Knight to
F6 with Knight to F3 and pawn to D4
uh grabbing more space in the center we
have Pawn to D3 and Knight to C6 so not
a very popular line but you know it's it
has been played and it has also been
played in the world cheers championship
match in 2021 between Magnus Carlsen and
diani Punisher so here we have castles
and Bishop to C5 reaching that exact
position from around nine uh of uh
Magnus versus nepo game and we have
Bishop to G5 and now uh there are a
couple of games that were Pawn to H6 was
played but here we have just Castles by
nikal and it is now already as of move
seven that we have a completely new game
so now Knight beat the D2 uh Bishop back
to E7 and as you know the Knight is
probably coming to B3 it's gonna put
pressure on the bishop but also you you
want um to move the Knight and trade off
that strong dark Square Bishop white has
on G5 so Knight to E1 and now we have
quanta E5 stopping Pawn to F4 and also
freeing up the light Square Bishop
Knights the C2 now grabbing more control
over the B4 square and of course Pawn to
A5 stopping and if you future B4 ideas
white still prepares at Pawn to A3 and
now Knight to D7 offering a trade of
Bishops we have Bishop characters Queen
characters and now Rook to E1 we have
Knight back to F6 and now Rook to B1
really getting ready to push B4 so nihal
tries to stop it for the moment Pawn to
A4 but now B for uh all the same and of
course you all know what happens here a
capture some B3 Alpha saw Knight
captures on B3 and now Rook to d8 we
have Queen to D2 developing the queen
connecting Rooks and now Bishop to F5
and now how do you continue
uh in this position it's a very tricky
one and one move that really that does
not come to mind is night to be for it's
a very nice move uh even though the uh
A3 Pawn is sort of hanging but so is the
Knight on C6 not the Knight but if you
capture once then the pawn and C6 will
be hanging so Rook captures on A3
doesn't really make all that much sense
but this invites black to go for a very
very aggressive uh move and that is Pawn
to E4 and now look at this Knight
captures on C6 attacks the Queen B
captures Now Pawn to E3 we have D
captures on E3 Wing captures and now
Rook captures an A3 or queen captures
but root captures is probably better D
captures on e4 as the E4 Pawn is now
defended three times Bishop back to E6
and now Pawn to E5 and Knight to D7 and
you have this position where probably a
bit too much to go F4 because there are
so many pieces on the board would be
pretty dangerous for the white Kings but
still it's uh you know it doesn't look
all that bad so it's definitely an
option but black also doesn't seem to
mind playing this so he decides against
this not going for Knight to B4 instead
Bishop captures on C6 by Axel B captures
and now Queen to B4 offering a queen
trade Queen to D6 and nihas is all right
let's trade Queens but uh I prefer to we
do it on my terms so I'm going to
undouble my pawns and of course Knight
the C5 axle uh prevents this you do not
want to attack the queen with Rook to B8
if some of you were thinking that and I
know you were because then just Queen
captures rook and you are very happy to
give up the queen for two Rooks here
um as you don't really have all that
much after that characters captures and
captures which check how the how do you
block this you have to play Queen to f8
and then you're just dead lost so after
Knight the C5 rooked the E8 displayed
and now pawned the F3 really stopping
that pawn from coming to E4 Ponte H5 uh
now stopping Pawn to G4 and pawn to A4
uh Axel has a pass Pawn on A4 of course
he will now start pushing it we have
found the horny nihal wants to start an
attack against the white king as soon as
you played F3 you have weakened the G3
pawn and of course uh nihal hones in on
that weakness with Knight to B7
attacking the queen queen to E6 and now
Knight back to C5 and nihal just says
all right Queen to D6 I already won the
first game I although you know I could
play on but I'm also very happy with the
drought going to round three of the
video World Cup 2023 so if you want to
play You're the one who is going to have
to find something to play here so he
does Axel finds King to F2 now the
position might open up then you might
put some Rooks on the G file could be be
dangerous for Nissan's King a knight to
H7 and now Pawn to A5 Axel continues
pushing his past a pawn Knights to G5
now you have to be very careful of
Knight to H3 check it's not deadly but
you know you have to calculate it every
move you make Rook to F1 and now Rook
the A7 preparing to double up on the a
file so you don't have to worry about
that past a pawn Rook to A1 and now Rook
e to A8 not just doubling up on the a
file and now Pawn to G4 and here
uh one uh could consider a lot of moves
and I will show you I will show you what
the engine plays uh and then I will show
you what Niha played and you know
although okay we kind of know that what
engine plays is best but I I very much
prefer what nihal played so the engine
says okay let's play Knight H3 check and
now after King to G2 we're gonna
re-maneuver the Knight to F4 it's a
better square and after King F2 we're
gonna re-maneuver the bishop over to C8
and our position is just better we have
a very nice Pawn on H4 the Knight it's a
monster on F4 uh so it is just a a
better position for black but now look
at what Niha played nihil played Ponte
E4 and this is such a tricky move uh you
probably have some ideas about this E4
move but you don't uh maybe you do maybe
you are of course an excellent player
but um I I did not think of this as soon
as I saw the C4 move and the idea is
that if now you play D captures on e4 uh
nihal's idea was a bishop captures on G4
and after Pawn captures Queen capture on
C5 a temporary Queen sacrifice because
after Queen captures and C5 Knight
captures an E4 check wins back the queen
and uh well that's just a wonderful
position Knight captures on C5 Knight
capture Sunday for Rook captures on A5
let's say captures captures
um
sorry captures captures uh and uh well
black is up upon whether anyhow would be
able to make something of this pawn it
is a double C Pawn so it's very very
hard to say Knight captures on C6 can be
played right away but then maybe the
pawns on the fourth rank become a little
bit weak so who knows what an eagle
decided about this uh all in all uh it
uh of course it can be refuted and
that's why the engine prefers Knight to
H3 but it's very very tricky so Axel
played the G captures on F5 he took the
bishop instead he doesn't want this
drawish line he captures an F3 first you
could go for Queen to H2 with the check
of course you could capture here you
could capture here you could push E3
check Queen captures Knight H3 check so
many moves are possible nihal goes for E
captures on F3 and it is the best move
you're not rushing with this and now how
does the white continue here and what
would you play here if I if I just show
you what what movie is best for white
you're not gonna believe me so I'm just
gonna show it uh King to E1 that's the
best move for white and it's the only
move that sort of holds for white uh
point is that after Rook to E8
threatening this uh Knight the E4 can be
played now Queen captures an H2
threatening Checkmate so you have to
play something uh e captures uh on F3
you have to go up the Knight and C2
first we're gonna play Knight captures
and E4 F characters undoubling the pawns
and now Queen captures on C2 but now
you're gonna bring the queen back and
you're gonna say okay I'm gonna hold
this not not a problem even though my
position looks really weird uh I I will
hold this however after he captures on
F3 who plays King E1 in this position
you you just don't play that King the G1
was played and now nihal is completely
winning and he does it beautifully he
plays F captures on E2 now threatens of
course The Rook on F1 Rook F to E1 and
now Queen to F4 the absolute strongest
move uh just taking away all of the
crucial squares from the black king from
the white king also Knight the H3 check
is coming next um
uh how can you how can you even start
defending this also Knight to F3 check
is a threat so real characters on E2 was
played and now Knight the H3 check King
to H1 and now there are many ways to
continue this uh but two of them are are
the the main star moves the queen F3
check and of course Rook captures on A5
Rook captures on A5 seems like you're
blundering a rook but you're really not
if Rook captures on A5 then Queen to F1
is it is made in one so instead after
Rook captures on A5 look at this Rook to
B1 and now we have Queen to F3 check
only move Rook to G2 and now Knights the
F2 with check this is unnecessary nehal
just repeats the position once uh but
you know he he gets the position back
into H1 and now the tricky part is that
uh you can play this uh uh uh you know
as many times as you want it it's a
great move but it's not the move that
actually wins the game you can just
repeat it a few times not too many times
because then it's a draw but there is
one move and it's such a beautiful so
strong a move uh that it you know white
just resigns once you see that move so
feel free to pause the video and try to
spot it while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh incredible smothered mate and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the move is Rook to A1 and this is
such a star move that uh I mean of
course uh now now that you see it you
you actually believe it because if Rook
captures an A1 uh We're not gonna play
that but then of course just Rook
captures on A1 uh and now there's
nothing to be done Knight captures on A1
Queen to F1 with check Rook to G1 and
queen captures and G1 is Checkmate but
of course we're not gonna do that what's
the idea behind Rook day one if we just
ignore the Rook we were saying okay our
B1 Rook is defended why do we even care
let's just play a move let's play 94.
what's the point the point is Queen to
F1 with check and now after Rook to G1
which seems like it shouldn't be
possible you will play Queen captures on
G1 sacrifice the queen and then Rook
captures on G1 will be a beautiful uh
Queen sacrifice Checkmate so the point
is after rookdale one you kind of have
to capture The Rook but with the Knight
so Knight captures on A1 was played and
now you've just blundered The Rook what
what's the point of Rook day one the
point is that now the Knight is not
blocking the other rook's path towards
the G2 Rook so here Rook to A2 so first
sacrificing The Rook on A1 and now Rook
to A2 and now there is no move how do
you stop Checkmate here that was the
whole point sorry uh nikal repeated once
that's the move you have to play but for
some reason nihal repeated Knight F2
checking G1 is three check King H1 so he
repeated this twice maybe just to
torture his opponent sometimes people
will do this for fun sort of play with
your food uh the chess version but yeah
you don't have to do this Rook to A2 and
it's just game over there's no way to
block this Rook to G1 is the only move
that stops Checkmate but it only stops
this Checkmate and it allows the other
one and that is the beautiful smarter
Checkmate you guys have seen in the
thumbnail uh the King has nowhere to go
The Rook is pinned of course cannot
capture a beautiful beautiful checkmate
beautiful game by nikal especially in
game 2 that he didn't have to win he
could have just played okay he did all
for a draw there with with a repetition
of moves uh but yeah I mean you don't
have to play like this in um yeah you're
not in a must win situation so it's
really a treat uh treated us to this uh
with the black piece in such an
important game and he goes into the next
round of the video World Cup um uh yeah
so I don't forget I will show you guys
uh the uh who is playing cool in round
three correct uh sorry about that I have
prepared it I just don't know where yeah
I've saved it here in a different
different folder for some reason
sometimes my brain does weird stuff uh
but yeah there you have it uh so these
are some of the pairings the top uh the
top some some top ten uh magnets will be
facing ariantari so the the Norwegian
Clash on top board I mean tabatabai will
be facing Vincent kymer uh now will be
facing Anton korbo the vasel Evancho
will be facing Wei now that is truly a
great fight on board four I'm expecting
a bloodbath there uh
will be saying Rasmus David Howell who I
believe he took out even charity in
round two will be facing one how uh
Parkway who will be facing andreasipenko
and naranan will be facing to uh very
strong Indians facing there Anish giri
will be facing ninja abasov and Peter
swindler will be facing Jordan fan
Forest so there you have it those are
only some of the boards and since we've
checked out nihao's game let me just
quickly check who nihal will be facing
uh kind of makes sense that I also
mentioned this um will be facing uh bogd
and Daniel dark a very strong Romanian
Grandmaster and also a vidit will be
facing Matthias bluebound yeah yeah and
I promise you will be facing a rough
Muhammad of and so on and so on but yeah
those are those are the top boards
basically beautiful game by nihal uh
very very nicely done and yeah good luck
to him on on becoming the seventh Indian
who will be rated over 20 700 and that's
uh I mean that's uh definitely India is
is truly is a Powerhouse uh then now
it's not just that that they have Anand
who was you know uh fighting against the
entire world alone now everyone is
coming uh basically everyone who Anand
tutored the all the way to 2700 plus uh
so yeah that's the game really hope you
guys enjoyed it once again uh uh a big
congratulations to nikal on such a
spectacular Checkmate I would like to
thank schlurture uh Paul Harris Samuel
Kane Aaron is the best wife and no Laura
is the best wife for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of This
Magnificent event until it finishes uh
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day